l'audition est ouverte
mes chers collègues nous connaissons
bien
monsieur castaner parce que il est
ministre des relations avec le parlement
c'est donc avec lui que se décide
l'ordre du jour du sénat
c'est à dire notre agenda pour la
discussion des projets de loi ce qui
explique que nous avons avec lui des
relations généralement camp dial donc je
le salue et il était important que nous
puissions l'auditionner ce matin mais il
est auditionné comme délégué général du
mouvement la république en marche et je
tiens à ce qu'il n'y ait aucune
ambiguïté à cet égard et d'ailleurs s'il
le permet je lui je le désignerait par
son titre monsieur le délégué général du
mouvement la république en marche
cette audition nous a paru nécessaire
d'abord parce que monsieur benalla était
accompagné de monsieur vincent kraz le
premier mec qui a lui même participé à
l'opération de maintien de l'ordre place
de la contrescarpe et peut-être
puisqu'une instruction est ouverte sur
ce point aussi au jardin des plantes
monsieur crasse portait une arme ce fait
a été établi par l'inspection générale
de la police nationale
et si j'ai bien compris monsieur cac
rasée par ailleurs salarié de
la république en marche nous voulons
aussi vous poser un certain nombre de
questions qui éclaireront le contexte de
l'emploi de monsieur benalla la
présidence de la république sur les
activités qu'il avait pour le mouvement
en marche et pour la campagne
présidentielle si ce point peut-être
éclairer par monsieur castaner avant
l'élection de monsieur emmanuel macron à
la présidence de la république
nous avons aussi à poser un certain
nombre de questions sur la diffusion des
parts d adhérence et j'ai bien compris
de ce mouvement d' images qui
proviennent en réalité de l'image de
vidéosurveillance transmise à l'elysée
qui peuvent avoir été transmise au
mouvement la république en marche
l'ensemble de ces questions et d'autres
qui est pourrait naître de nos échanges
vont donc vous est posée dans un instant
mais avant cela je dois rappeler un
certain nombre de règles
je les fais pour chacun d'eux ou
interdits de nos interlocuteurs
un faux témoignage devant notre
commission des lois doté des
prérogatives d'une commission denquête
serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
damende je vous invite à prêter serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure je le jure monsieur le président je
vous remercie
je vais vous proposer si vous le
souhaitez de faire un bref propos
liminaire à la suite duquel je donnerai
la parole à notre
rapporteur nos rapporteur madame jourda
monsieur le président en sueur je
penserai peut être moi même une ou deux
questions
puis les membres de la commission des
lois qui se seront inscrits et je vous
invite à le faire au fur et à mesure
vous poseront une question et ils ont un
gentillet ce de la pause et en moins
d'une minute dix ans remercie ça n'est
pas une règle contraignante c'est une
règle dont nous sommes convenus pour
permettre à chacun de poser une question
sans retarder trop les personnes
auditionnées et puis les collègues
sénatrices et sénateurs non membre de la
commission poseront ensuite s'ils le
souhaitent leurs propres questions voilà
comment va se dérouler cette audition
étant entendu que mes chers collègues si
nous pouvions libérer le terme est
impropre car monsieur que c'est à dire
n'est pas séquestré par notre commission
des lois à l'évidence pour voir si nous
pouvions laisser partir monsieur
castaner à temps pour qu'il soit 10
heures à la conférence des présidents de
l'assemblée nationale dont j'ai compris
qu'elle se réunissaient elle ne pourra
pas se réunir sans lui ce serait mieux
mais monsieur monsieur le délégué
général si les débats se poursuivent
j'essaye de vous aider mais si les
débats se poursuivent
il faudra bien qu'on arrive au bout de
l'audition bon alors donc eh bien
maintenant c'est vous qui prenez la
parole si vous le souhaitez merci
monsieur le président madame
l'accord emporte terme sur le
co-rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs je sois tout d'abord vous
remercier monsieur le président
or bien voulu accepter le report de 24
heures de mon audition qu'avaient
envisagé hier j'ai fait l'objet d'une
intervention chirurgicale avec
anesthésie générale vendredi et j'avais
peur que mon état ne permettent pas
d'être suffisamment alerte pour éclairer
votre enquête pour avoir regardé par
vidéo les questions que vous posez une
trouble nécessaire d'être suffisamment
alerte
je dis monsieur le délégué général vous
n'êtes pas obligé de tourner la tête
vers moi pour répondre à mes questions
je comprendrais très bien je vous
remercie de cette attention médicale
je tiens à rappeler ma volonté
d'apporter au sénat tous les éléments
dont j'ai connaissance afin de faire
toute la lumière sur les conditions dans
lesquelles des événements du 1er mai
sont intervenus et d'éclairer votre
commission des lois en charge de cette
enquête je vais pas rappeler l'objet
avant toute chose je tiens à redire que
j'étais personnellement choqué par ces
images et je ne doute pas que chacune et
chacun ici l'ont été tout autant je
condamne une nouvelle fois les actes
auxquels se sont livrés messieurs
alexandre benalla et vincent kraz le 1er
mai dernier
ils sont contraires aux valeurs portées
par notre république par le mouvement
politique que je préside
mon objectif monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs est clair vous
apporter tous les éléments dont j'ai eu
et j'ai connaissance en lien avec cette
journée du 1er mai tout d'abord si je
m'exprime devant vous aujourd'hui c'est
dans ma qualité de déléguée générale de
la république en marche fonctions que
j'assume depuis mon élection le 18
novembre 2017
compte tenu du fait voulait rappeler
monsieur le président qu'un salarié de
la république en marche est impliqué en
tant que délégué général je suis le
représentant légal toujours depuis le 18
novembre 2007 de l'association la
république en marche mais également
l'employeur de tous les salariés du
mouvement c'est dans ce cadre que je
souhaite vous faire part des faits tels
que je les ai vécus le 2 mai une vidéo
tournée la veille a été très largement
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux où elle
a été vue plus de 100 mille fois
plusieurs salariés la réplique en marche
nous ont vus ils ont été stupéfaits lire
connaître un de leurs collègues
en l'occurrence vincent kra ce qu'ils
connaissent bien puisqu'il est l'un des
agents en charge de l'accueil et de la
sécurité du siège la réplique en marche
ils ont également reconnu pour certains
d'entre eux alexandre benalla que
certains avaient pu croiser durant la
campagne présidentielle
j'ai été informé ce même jour le 2 mai
aux alentours de 18 heures alerter j'ai
alors visionner sur mon téléphone cette
vidéo présente dans les locaux de la
république en marche à cette heure là
j'y arrivais j'ai souhaité voir vincent
case vers 18h15 en présence de mon
directeur de cabinet françois blouvac et
du responsable sécurité sûreté le
supérieur hiérarchique de l'instant
traces pierre-yves barratier
immédiatement pour lui demander des
explications sur ce que cette vidéo
révélée pour information vincent kra
s'occupe depuis le 1er juillet 2010 est
un poste de responsable
joint sûreté sécurité au sein des
effectifs de la république en marche
en tant que non cadres et sous
l'autorité d'un chef de sécurité dans un
service de huit personnes qui a
notamment la charge de l'accueil et la
surveillance des locaux de l'association
je tiens à votre disposition de ceux
présents madame monsieur cours à porter
l'organigramme de ce service lors de cet
entretien vincent kraz indiqué avoir agi
en tant que gendarme réserviste le
premier mais à la demande expresse
d'alexandre benalla avec il indiqué être
en contact dans le cadre d'opérations
réalisées elles aussi en tant que
gendarme réserviste vincent kazma alors
informé qu'il était chef d'escadron
gendarme de réserve depuis 1996 rattaché
à l'elysée dans un cadre extra
professionnelles il a ensuite confirmé
que les faits étaient intervenus en
dehors de son temps de travail la
république en marche
en dehors de toute information de sa
hiérarchie et qui n'en avait pas rendu
compte
c'est d'ailleurs dans ce cadre je cite
ouvrez les guillemets gendarmes
réservistes par ailleurs employé de la
réplique en marche qu'il est identifié
par monsieur bruno roger petit porte
parole de la république de la présence
de la république
pour information cet entretien n'a duré
que quelques minutes puisque je
présidais à bureau exécutif à 18h30
devant effectuer le lendemain un
déplacement de trois jours dans l'eure
et loir du 3 au 5 mai j'ai demandé à mon
directeur de cabinet françois blouvac et
aux supérieurs hiérarchiques directs de
vincent grass pierre-yves barratier de
le recevoir
le 3 mai le lendemain pour définir les
suites à donner ainsi bien que ces faits
se soient déroulés hors de son cadre de
travail et la réplique à marche j'ai
souhaité le sanctionner parce que je
considère grave ce qui s'est passé j'en
ai fait indique à vingt cinq races que
d'une part son comportement lors du 1er
mai est en total décalage avec
l'attitude attendu des salariés de la
république en marche et notamment ceux
chargés de l'accueil de la sécurité du
mouvement y compris en dehors de leur
temps de travail et d'autre part qu'une
telle attitude porter atteinte à l'image
du mouvement qui l'emploie dans la
mesure où les faits se sont déroulés
alors que vincent kra zoom avait indiqué
qu'il intervenait en tant que réserve et
ce à la demande de monsieur benalla j'ai
souhaité pan de la tâche du directeur de
cabinet de la présidence de la
république pour connaître les suites à
donner et que la sanction infligée à
monsieur kraz soient liées à celles
retenues à l'encontre de monsieur
benalla un échange a eu lui rentre mon
directeur de cabinet et le directeur de
cabinet de l'après
the republic à ce sujet et c'est sur la
base de cet échange que j'ai donc
notifiée le 3 mai par courrier à vincent
kra la sanction de suspension de quinze
jours du 4 au 18 mai inclus depuis
l'ouverture de l'enquêté judiciaire j'ai
adressé vendredi 20 juillet vincent
gazin croyait lui indiquant que la
réplique en marche lancé une procédure
de licenciement à son encontre fondés
sur le trouble objectif au
fonctionnement de l'association et
l'atteinte portée à son image
aujourd'hui sur la base du rapport
établi par l'inspection générale de la
police nationale
j'ai pu constater qu'outre la faute
monsieur kraz ajouté le mensonge
puisqu'il n'était pas ni présents ce
jour en tant que gendarme réserviste ne
bénéficier d'aucune autorisation pour
être présent il a été présenté aux
autorités comme un collaborateur de
monsieur benalla et je note que le
rapport de l'igpn précise que là encore
je cite alexandre benalla est accompagné
pour la circonstance d'une seconde
personne qui le présente comme un
collaborateur en l'occurrence vincent
grass le major misère ce qui ne connaît
pas monsieur kraz mais ne demandent pas
d'explication compte tenu du statut de
monsieur benalla représentant affiché
est reconnu comme tel par sa hiérarchie
de la présence de la république le
rapport de l'igpn établit donc
clairement que l'activité salariée de
vincent kra ce n'est en aucun cas lié à
sa présence ce jour là le général
bio-farina le confirme d'ailleurs lors
de son audition à l'assemblée nationale
quand il précise que je cite encore
monsieur kraz que j'ai eu au téléphone
pour lui dire qu'il ne reviendrait plus
à l'elysée m'a dit qu'il avait suivi
alexandre benalla de son propre chef
ce jour là sur ces bases je suis
maintenant totalement disponibles pour
répondre à toutes vos questions
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
délégué général qui ouvre la question
monsieur de président en sueur oui
monsieur le délégué général
vous savez qu'ici nous n'avons qu'un
seul combat dans cette commission
denquête le combat pour la vérité pour
mettre à jour les dysfonctionnements
et pour faire des propositions afin de
remédier à ces dysfonctionnements
c'est dire que nous nous attachons au
fait et je vais vous poser des questions
très ponctuel et ma collègue muriel
jourda
peut-être ne sera plus attachés à
d'autres aspects euh je voulais vous
dire aussi que dans votre propos
liminaire vous savez déjà apporté des
éléments de réponse qui m'ont pékin-
kerandon certaines questions inutiles
donc vous savez eu l'occasion de
reparler avec monsieur vincent kra ce
qui est le salarié de la république en
marche depuis les faits vous confirmez
donc que lorsque celui ci s'est retrouvé
le 1er mai sur ces lieux d'opération il
n'avait nullement le statut
d'observateur c'est à dire que pour
monsieur benalla la question s'est posée
il avait sollicité où on lui avait
proposé cela n'est toujours pas très
clair un statut d'observateur
monsieur kraz est venu de manière
informelle à la suggestion de monsieur
ben adda vous pouvez confirmer cela
messieurs délégué général sur la base
des informations qu'il m'a communiqué et
sur la base aussi du rapport de l'igpn
votre question apporte une réponse
claire les n'avait nullement le statut
d'observateur il n'a jamais fait état de
cela dans le court entretien que j'ai pu
avoir avec lui il n'a pas fait date cela
le lendemain dans l'entretien qu'il a eu
avec mon directeur de cabinet et son
responsable hiérarchique
il a toujours précisé alexandre benalla
dont il était proche été relevées
notamment par le général bio-farina dans
une des auditions alexandre benalla m'a
appelé et m'a dit de venir et il est
très bien donc on peut bien entendu et
je pense que vous pourrez partager cette
appréciation être étonné devant le
caractère purement informel de cette
procédure dans le cadre de la police
nationale par le fait aussi que il y ait
eu ce comportement
les actes de molestage des personnes et
qu' il n'y a eu aucune remontée le
interne à la police c'est à dire que ni
le préfet de police ni le ministre de
l'intérieur n'ont reçu le moindre compte
rendu de ce qui s'est passé puisque ils
ont été informés le 2 mai par l'elysée
vous même vous avez été informé de ces
faits le 2 mai passent avant nous
voulons faire
merci je suis comme vous étonner mais je
pense que comme cela était président
rapport de l'igpn de major lazer ce qui
compte tenu du statut de monsieur pénale
a n'a pas osé aller plus loin il devrait
certainement du oui absolument
vous n'avez eu aucune information ni le
1er mai ni de 2 many ensuite sur les
événements qui reste à confirmer puisque
une enquête préliminaire a été ouverte
qui ont eu lieu préalablement au jardin
des plantes n'ont à aucun moment
merci ensuite la question c'est sans
doute posé pour vous comme elle s'est
posée pour les différentes personnes que
nous avons interrogées de savoir si vu
la gravité des faits parce que voilà
quelqu'un qui est sur un théâtre
d'opérations de la police qui prend
l'initiative d'une action physique sans
aucune autorisation et sans aucune
qualité pour le faire qui sans doute
usurpe un certain nombre de signes
distinctifs de la police et qui est
l'objet d'une sanction
bon mais vous n'avez pas pensé en tant
que président du mouvement saisir la
justice 17 dès ce stade
et sinon pourquoi
pour quelles raisons tout simplement
parce que vincent grass m'a déclaré
intervenir comme gendarme réserviste
auprès de l'elysée et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je n'avais pas mon sens a
jugé les conditions de son intervention
et c'est vrai que dans la lettre que je
lui ai adressé le lendemain je lui
rappelais que sa participation aux
manifestations et son comportement à
cette occasion et en décalage complet
avec l'attitude attendu d'une personne
en charge l'accueil la sécurité mais
gahler également je voulais rappeler des
valeurs de notre mouvement mais ne met
pas apparu nécessaire d'évaluer la
proportionnalité de l'intervention de
quelqu'un qui me disait intervenir comme
gendarme réserviste du coup placé sous
l'autorité des gens auprès desquels il
était placé les faits ont établi depuis
que ça n'était pas le cas et donc
évidemment cette explication là ne
justifie en rien n'est fait chers
collègues mais eux
je lui dis qu'un intérêt rétrospectif
mais même gendarme réserviste l'elysée
vous auriez pu signaler aux parquets
seront comportement pendant la
manifestation
et puisque vous avez été en contact avec
le directeur de cabinet du président de
la république à propos de l'intervention
de monsieur grâce aux côtés de monsieur
benalla un échange at il eu lieu sur
cette question de la transmission au
parquet à charge pour lui d'apprécier
l'opportunité des poursuites de du
dossier de monsieur écrase le président
comme je lé précisé dans mon propos
liminaire avec pour compléter par
rapport à votre question dès lors que la
justification de sa présence était son
statut de gendarme réserviste auprès de
l'elysée c'est vrai que j'ai pris
l'initiative de demander qui a un
contact avec le directeur de cabinet du
président à pic pour s'assurer d'abord
que le cabinet du président de la
république était informée il l'était
mais je le sais maintenant le 2 mai au
soir je n'avais pas cette information là
et donc j'ai vérifié évidemment cela met
ensuite considérant qu'il s'agissait de
faits commis dans le cadre de ses
fonctions deux gendarmes réservistes
auprès la présence de la république
j'ai souhaité appliquer le parallélisme
des formes de la sanction décidée pour
l'auteur qui me semblait l'auteur
principal
ce benalla à l'auteur accessoires et il
n'y a pas de hiérarchisation dans mon
propos mais plutôt une référence
juridique concernant monsieur crasse et
c'est vrai que c'est d'ailleurs aussi la
sanction immédiate dont il a fait
l'objet de la part du général bio farina
qui l'a démis de ses fonctions au sein
de la réserve qui dans mon esprit montre
bien sanctions dont j'ai eu connaissance
qu'au moment des auditions qui montre
bien que ce statut là était celui qui
l'avait mise en avant
monsieur sûr je voulais aussi vous
demander
puisqu'il est établi que monsieur kraz
intervenez ponctuellement pour la
présidence de la république
s'il y avait une convention ou un acte
quelconque qui stipulait les relations
entre la république en marche et la
présidence de la république pour ce qui
est de l'emploi de monsieur kraz ou
est-ce que c'était pour moi informelle
s'était en effet plus ou moins formels
il m'est indiqué qu'une mission de
réservistes s'effectuer en dehors des
heures de service de vincent kraz c'est
vrai qu'il a des horaires particuliers
de gardiennage qui lui permettait
d'intervenir
et c'est en entendant les auditions pour
préparer celle ci notamment que j'ai
appris que monsieur vincent gaz avait
réalisé 40 missions entre novembre 2010
à terville 2018 pour le compte de la
présence de la république le
commandement militaire de la présidence
de la république
une information que je n'avais pas
n'avait pas trop n'avez vous pas trouvé
étrange que la sanction à l'égard de
monsieur crasse dont vous êtes
l'employeur a été annoncée par monsieur
bruno roger petit porte parole de
l'elysée d'abord elle est annoncée par
mon directeur de cabinet à monsieur kraz
dans lequel est publiquement les
publiquement effectivement je n'ai pas à
juger si ces étranges ou pas j'ai
découvert les propos du porte parole de
la présidence de la république
peut-être comme vous en les écoutant
lorsque monsieur benalla a été licencié
cela était justifiée par le fait qu'il y
avait eu un nouvel événement à savoir
que celui ci s'était procuré où s'était
vu offrir et qu'il avait accepté des
vidéos de manière illégale
quel est l'événement qui a justifié
qu'au delà de la mise à pied vous ayez
procéder au licenciement de monsieur
kraz d'abord préciser que nous sommes
dans la procédure de licenciement et
qu'il est convoqué à un entretien tout à
l'heure hasard de calendrier
mais les délais entre la lettre envoyée
en recommandé et la convocation fait que
l'entretien a lieu tout à l'heure moi je
considère que les récents événements ont
porté à notre connaissance des faits
nouveaux et ont mis en lumière la
gravité de ces comportements
comportements que je condamne que nous
condamnons et ces faits sont
susceptibles je pense de jeter le
discrédit sur notre mouvement
ils ont porté publiquement atteinte à
nos valeurs
je rajoute même à ce que je suis moi
c'est certainement pas une raison pour
justifier un licenciement mais c'est au
moins une raison je vous le dis pour
assumer un risque de contentieux devant
les prud'hommes et c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette nouvelle procédure a été
initiée que vincent gaz est convoqué
dans ce cadre là s'agissant des vidéos
qui ont donc été offertes ou que
l'intéressé s'est procuré je ne sais pas
encore quelle est la vérité auprès de
trois agents de la préfecture de police
de paris
avez vous vu ces vidéos non
2 il a été établi que une copie de ces
vidéos avaient été remises par monsieur
benalla à un conseiller de la présidence
de la république monsieur meulien eux et
eux ensuite il a été établi qu'un
certain nombre de je ne sais pas comment
dire de sites sous de compte voilà deux
comptes sur les réseaux sociaux ont
reproduit cette vidéo
bien entendu on voit tout à fait
l'intérêt de cette vidéo si l'on peut
dire puisque celle ci présente les
événements qui se sont déroulés en amont
et comme en amour il était établi aussi
que des personnes avaient porté atteinte
aux forces de l'ordre en lançant des
projectiles
cela pouvait naturellement justifier une
réponse encore que la réponse du dû
venir des forces des victimes de la
police comme vous le savez avez vous été
au courant du fait qu'un certain nombre
de comptes appartenant à des membres de
la république en marche ont été activés
pour cette occasion
non je n'ai aucune information sur ce
sujet le comme vous l'article qui en a
fait l'état d'abord chassé mediapart
qu'il a abordés ça a été repris ensuite
aucun membre de ma connaissance de la
république en marche ne les a relayés
pour tout vous dire je ne sais pas du
tout quels comptes ont été évoqués je
crois pas qu'il le soit dans l'article
de mediapart il ya une enquête
judiciaire je me tient évidemment à
disposition à la fois de votre
commission mais la foi de tout cadre
judiciaire aussi pour faire la vérité
sur ce sujet je n'ai connaissance
d'aucun membre
il ya 4 semblait de membres de la
réplique en marche qui aurait relayé
cela donc vous n'avez pas non plus
d'informations par rapport à eux à la
décision qui semble avoir été prise de
retirer l'ensemble de ces images de ses
comptes ce qui a eu lieu de manière
simultanée
et qui témoigne naturellement du fait
que quelques personnes attachées au
droit se sont rendus compte qu'il y
avait là un problème juridique
donc vous n'avez pas vu la cassette vous
n'avez pas évoqué la question avec le
conseiller de l'elysée qui l'a reçue qui
a pu l'amener être destinataire vous
n'avez pas été au courant du fait qu'un
certain nombre de comptes de deux
personnes appartenant au mouvement la
règle bicoeur marche les ont diffusés et
vous n'avez pas non plus eu connaissance
d'une quelconque initiative visant pour
des raisons juridiques évidente à
retirer ces images de ses comptes une
connaissance de ces images que quelques
minutes avant qu'elle soit annoncée par
bfm je crois qu'il était le premier
média à le sortir puis par la lecture
que j'ai eue de l'article de mediapart
sur ce sujet à aucun moment dans ma
maison ma république en marche
je n'ai été informée de quelconque
présence de ces images une quelconque
utilisation de ces images est mon
information a eus ar anticipé de
quelques minutes parce que le microcosme
en parlait seulement la diffusion il
dernière n'avait une connaissance d'
aucune instruction ni initiatives prises
par aucun cadre responsable de la
république en marche à l'égard de
l'apparition sur des comptes de ces
images et de leur disparition ensuite je
suis même convaincu qu aucune
instruction n'a été donnée jeudi
convaincu et avec la limite de ma
conviction qu aucune instruction n'a été
donnée parmi les cadres ou les
responsables
pouvez vous me citer les greens herald
en marche nous préciser l'organisation
de la communication de la république en
marche avec les réseaux sociaux il y à
un pôle communication majoritaire il ya
un pôle communication au sein de la
république en marche je vous propose de
vous remettre tout à l'heure
l'organigramme qui est sûre la commision
communication stratégique et qui traite
la question du développement notamment
du développement de notre site des
médias de la riposte de l'opinion des
événements et du porte parolat du
mouvement effectivement il y avait un
certain nombre de spécialistes dont
j'aurais du mal à définir toutes les
missions mais de spécialiste de la
gestion de plateformes numériques
notamment du site de la république en
marche mais ils n'ont pas vocation à
diffuser des vidéos non officiel de la
république en marche
nous diffusons presque tous les jours
des vidéos des capsules vidéo que nous
réalisons mais en aucun cas d'autres
formes de médias combien de personnes y
travaillent alors on organisait un mec
m'a totalement à jour celui celui du
mois voilà celui du mois de mai 2010huit
état de 25 équivalents temps plein sur
le pôle communication et développement
et il ya aussi des militants qui
bénévolement s'ajoute à cette équipe
alors sous réserve de vérification les
seuls bénévoles qui interviennent en
fait interviennent pour ce qu'on appelle
le service après vente c'est à dire
c'est moi qui l'appelle ainsi
c'est à tous les gens qui appellent qui
envoient des mails qui interroge le
mouvement et qui aident à gérer les
quelques agents professionnels dans les
éléments de réponse mais il n'y a pas de
militants qui interviennent sur la
communication directe ce n'est ensuite
comme militants sur leur territoire sur
la communication directe de mouvement
c'est sûr j'ai posé toutes mes questions
monsieur le président dont je vous
remercie pour vos réponses merci
beaucoup madame jourda merci monsieur le
président monsieur délégué général je
mets volontairement de vous regarder
pour que vous faisiez de même et que
vous n'aviez pas votre état de santé
alors première question qui est relative
à l'organisation des services du de
votre mouvement politique
comment organisez-vous la sécurité avait
vous recours à des prestataires
extérieurs
où avez-vous à une division interne il
ya au sein des services est prévu aussi
la petite fiche d'organisation un pas
l'administration et finances qui a une
responsable de service qui chapote un
service qui s'appelle sécurité et sûreté
dans ce service sécurité sûreté il ya un
responsable qui arrive barratier il ya
deux chefs d'equipe vincent case était
un des deux chefs d'equipe il y à un
serpent et il y a deux agents de
sécurité
il ya aussi quelques agents en charge
spécifiquement de l'accueil la nuit et
le week-end il y à une société
extérieure qui intervient pour le compte
de la république en marche et qui assure
seulement la sécurité
ouverture fermeture du site c'est la
société go
je vous remercie
l'information que nous avions été que
monsieur kraz n'était qu'un agent
d'accueil en fait d'une confirmé qu'il
il a bien un titre relatif à une
question relative à la sécurité est il
titulaire d'une habilitation du cnaps à
cet effet alors attendez je reprends
l'intitulé exact des missions qu'il a
aux simples qu'ils avaient je crois
qu'il a toujours d'ailleurs sa position
n'a pas abouti il occupe un emploi de
responsable adjoint sûreté et sécurité
dans les locaux de l'association
catégorie non cadres sous l'autorité
selon les directives de son supérieur
hiérarchique sans que la liste ne soit
exhaustive les missions du salarié sont
les suivantes
c'est la fiche de poste assurer la
surveillance générale des locaux de
l'association assurer la sécurité des
biens et des personnes
assurer la surveillance technique des
locaux des équipements assurer l'accueil
l'information et l'orientation des
visiteurs
le cas échéant accompagner des
personnalités de l'association à
l'extérieur je précise d'ailleurs sur ce
sujet pour avoir lu quotidiens parus ce
matin que jamais monsieur kraz ne m'a
accompagné dans mes déplacements et
encore moins de façon armés ce qui était
écrit dans le journal libération ce
matin est un mensonge
je tiens à le préciser parce que je
pense qu'il est inutile de rajouter des
éléments faux à une instruction qui est
déjà compliquée que vous conduisez sous
votre autorité monsieur le président
voilà les missions qui sont les siennes
il est titulaire d'un agrément cnaps sur
ses missions là et j'ai lu dans la
presse qu'il avait fait une demande
d'agrément mais comme responsables de
sociétés qui lui a été refusé mais ce
qui selon des informations non lève rien
au fait que il a bien aujourd'hui la
carte professionnelle délivrée par le
conseil national des activités produits
de sécurité
en fait j'ai quatre professionnels comme
nous l'indiqué qui sont munis de cette
carte professionnelle et cette carte
professionnelle des habilités à exercer
des missions de sécurité privée
et nous avons également un agent de
sécurité est chauffeur l'agent de
sécurité incendie et deux équipes je
vous le dis dédiée à l'animation et
décalé c'est une petite équipe
ce n'est en aucun cas une milice qualité
le rôle de deuxième kraz au moment de la
campagne électorale du candidat emmanuel
mac ou alors je n'avais pas moins de
responsabilités organisationnelles dans
la campagne j'étais en fonction de porte
parole du candidat mais j'ai fait
établir un certain des éléments que je
peux reproduire le mouvement en marche
entretenait des relations contractuelles
ponctuelles avec vincent case en tant
que prestataire depuis novembre 2010 est
il intervenait comme super ce support
sur des missions de sécurité
ça n'est que le 1er juillet 2010 est que
son statut a changé il est embauché par
le mouvement la république en marche
avec un contrat à durée indéterminée et
2016 pardon novembre 2016 oui j'ai dit
on a pu observer que plusieurs acteurs
de la sécurité privée du candidat en
marche se sont trouvés devant les dans
les rangs de l'elysée si je puis dire
pour le président de la république dans
des fonctions qui avait trait à la
sécurité il le monsieur maxence benalla
qui étaient acteurs de la sécurité
pendant la campagne qui est adjoint au
chef de cabinet coordinateur de sa
sécurité
monsieur kraz dont on a indiqué dans
quelles circonstances ils se trouvaient
également à l'elysée est également un
ancien membre du gign qui avait
travaillé pour la sécurité du candidat
en marche qui se retrouvaient
contractuels aujourd'hui j'espère
notamment pour ce dernier cette dernière
personne ce dernier membre de la
sécurité du candidat en marche
il nous a été indiqué que quelqu'un est
intervenue
pour le faire embaucher au j'espère êtes
vous intervenu pour faire embaucher
cette personne ou les deux autres
personnes d'ailleurs aucune t3 je suis
intervenu je ne t'ai pas en
responsabilité au sein d'an marche au
moment où ses équipes ont été
constituées ces recrutements ont été
faits et pour la troisième personne je
n'ai entendu parler qui hier dans
l'audition de jean marie cherrier
[Musique]
merci et madame deux rapporteurs
monsieur jacques bigot même jeu délégué
général vous dites que vous avez été
choqué que l'attitude monsieur prince
comme celle de monsieur benalla était
contraire aux valeurs de votre mouvement
un mouvement politique désormais
important en france et pourtant vous
n'avez rien fait pour que l'information
au public soit portée de sorte que les
policiers ont considéré que tout le
monde
en voyant ces vidéos première celle que
vous avez visionné le domaine
discréditer la police donnait
l'impression que des policiers avaient
ainsi agi et à aucun moment il ne vous
est venu à l'idée que pour respecter vos
valeurs et recrédité la police de bons
comportements
vous auriez dû porter cette information
au public plutôt que de la terre aussi
bien pour monsieur b n'est là que pour
monsieur kraz c'est le délégué général
j'ai déjà je pense avoir répondu à cette
question mais je vais la renouveler j'ai
considéré que je n'avais pas à me
substituer à l'autorité de monsieur kraz
celui-ci n'agissons pas dans le cadre
des fonctions de la reine dans le cadre
de missions de gendarmes réservistes
placée sous l'autorité de la présidence
de la république et qui ne m'appartenait
pas moi d'évaluer la proportionnalité
des conditions d'intervention de
monsieur crasse merci de cette réponse
madame lherbier monsieur le
10dans monsieur le délégué général vous
dit forcément que les actes sont
contraires aux valeurs de votre
mouvement
elles sont ces actes sont contraires
tout simplement la démocratie et c'est
pour ça que nous sommes tous ici nous
avons tous été choqués par ces actes
comme disait monsieur bigot qui
pouvaient discrédité l'image de la
police moi je voulais vous revenir sur
monsieur benalla on nous a dit que
monsieur benalla et on vire on le sent
dans les interrogations différentes se
servait de son statut pourrait vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure pour
solliciter un collaborateur pour
solliciter des personnes autour de lui
avez vous déjà pu constater cette
manière de faire pendant la campagne at
il déjà montré une certaine un abus
d'autorité parce qu'il était proche du
président auprès de vos militants
auprès d'eux des personnes que vous
connaissez pas ce que ça c'est important
pour nous de savoir si si monsieur
benalla se sert de de cette proximité
avec monsieur le président pour agir sur
le délégué général
merci madame la sénatrice je partage
évident aux propos sur les valeurs que
nous avons en commun j'ai dans mon pot
polymère commencé par saluer celle de
les valeurs de la république et je sais
qu'elle nous rassemble tous d'ici et pas
seulement ici
heureusement et ensuite tout
particulièrement pour le mouvement dont
j'ai la responsabilité et sainte exclu
aucun des autres mouvements politiques
qui sont ici présents et j'ai été
surpris parce qu'il m'a été rapporté
notamment de l'affluence que monsieur
benalla pouvait semble-t-il avoir sur
monsieur kraz parce que si pendant la
campagne n'est jamais une relation
personnelle avec monsieur benalla je le
rencontrais régulièrement et cela s'est
toujours fait de façon cordiale et à
chaque fois que nécessaire
efficace je les croisais pour la
première fois dans le cas d'un président
la campagne présidentielle alors que
j'étais un des porte parole du candidat
emmanuel macron il était en charge des
questions de sécurité
je vais vous dire je n'ai jamais assisté
à un moment une de tension particulier
sur sur ces sujets je peux pas j'ai
réfléchi à quel moment précisément je
l'avais rencontré la première fois c'est
entre la fin 2016 et le début de l'année
2017 mais voilà je n'ai pour répondre
très concrètement d'autres questions
savoir si j'ai pu constater des
influences négatives ou d'autorité de
monsieur benalla sur certaines personnes
de son entourage ou sur un abus de
fonctions liées à sa fonction de chargé
de mission à l'elysée
ça n'a jamais été le cas si ça avait été
le cas je voudrais référer au président
de la république monsieur jean pierre
sueur permettez-moi de revenir sur la
réponse que vous avez apporté à la
question de jacques bigot
si vous voulez j'ai le sentiment que
vous complétez le tableau et permettez
moi de parler un peu directement les
actes qui ont eu lieu le 1er mai son nom
même d'une très grande gravité
d'ailleurs où l'as veti avec beaucoup de
force comme le président de la
république l'a dit avec beaucoup de
force quand il a annoncé dans un
discours que certains ont entendu que
ces actes est inadmissible et
inacceptable
donc vraiment qu'un citoyen pourvu
d'aucun titre arrive de manière
informelle
dans une opération de sécurité publique
et se mettent à s'en prendre
physiquement à des citoyens sans aucun
mandat de sa propre initiative
c'est quand même quelque chose de grave
imaginez que chacun se comporte comme ça
il y aurait pu de règle dans notre
société
donc c'est inacceptable inadmissible or
par rapport à la question le 2 mai un
certain nombre de personnes sont au
courant
le 2 mai le premier il ya des
difficultés pour que ça remonte dans la
police et au ministère de l'intérieur
et alors si vous voulez après tout les
auditions nous nous rendons compte qu'il
y avait une sorte de renvoi de balle
tout à fait remarquable c'est monsieur
le préfet de police dit eh bien non il
ne me revenait pas de saisir la justice
parce que moi je suis préfet de police
je suis pas ministre l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre intérieur dit m'a
écouté non ce personnage il relève de
l'elysée à l'elysée nous avons rencontré
un certain nombre de personne ni
monsieur le directeur de cabinet ni
monsieur secrétaire général ni personne
ne considère qu'il y avait lieu de
saisir la justice
et quant à l'employeur que vous êtes au
titre de votre mouvement politique de
monsieur de l'un des deux protagonistes
vous pensez aussi que pour les raisons
vous expliquer il ne revenait pas il ne
vous revenez pas de saisir la justice
donc on est dans un système non je
retire le mot système on est disons dans
une configuration où sans doute pour des
raisons qui tiennent aux jugements que
chacun se fait mais personne ne juge
utile que ce soit lui qui saisissent la
justice de faits qui sont quand même
inacceptable inadmissible d'une grande
d'une très grande gravité
je vous demande simplement comment vous
réagissez pas revoir ce que je dis et si
vous le permettez pour compléter la
question la gravité de ces faits du
point de vue du code pénal est attestée
par le fait que le procureur de la
république quant à lui dès qu'il est
informé ouvre une enquête préliminaire
est au fond quand on transmet au
procureur de la république
des faits qui nous paraissent délictueux
nous ne sommes pas juges en réalité de
l'opportunité des poursuites
et c'est pas nous qui déclencheront la
l'action publique c'est bien le
procureur à lui d'apprécier
parfois on ne répond mais au moment des
faits j'ai considéré que les réactions
que nous avons eues était proportionnée
mais en réalité celui qui est assujettie
à une obligation de transmission
d'informations sur un délit au parquet
n'a pas à se poser la question de la
gravité des faits de lui même c'est le
procureur qui va se la poser et décider
éventuellement de classer sans suite
sans même ouvrir la moindre la moindre
information monsieur le délégué général
d'abord pour rebondir sur un mot pour
seul sénateurs sueur j'ai l'habitude
d'assumer mais d'assumer seul on se
connaît depuis assez longtemps de vous
sait pas quel est le bon mais mais mais
je j'assume je ne cherche pas à renvoyer
la balle sur qui que ce soit je crois
que la vérité est unique et que la
vérité quand on la regarde
à un moment donné dans mon cas sur un
téléphone portable sur une vidéo
et quand on le regarde plusieurs
semaines après avec des images
décortiqué étudier expliqué et tous les
commentaires qui vont avec finalement
elle n'est plus tout à fait la même mais
ma vérité pour moi les tuniques au
moment où je prends connaissance de ces
faits je suis choqué
j'interroge l'agent monsieur kraz qui me
dit intervenir dans le cadre de fonction
de gendarme réserviste auprès de la
présence de la république à ce moment là
je vous le dis et je les assume
mon regard n'est pas le même sur un
citoyen qui interviendrait dans la rue
par rapport à des forces de l'ordre qui
ce jour là avec la mobilisation de 1200
black blocks avec les conditions du 1er
mai je veux pas y revenir que vous
connaissez bien avec les dégration de
commerce de véhicules
quand vous avez une image de quelqu'un
qui vous dit j'intervenais et ce n'est
pas le cas mais moins d'informations que
j'essaie j'intervenais dans le cadre de
mes fonctions de gendarmes réservistes
sous l'autorité de la présidence de la
république
mon regard je vous le dis n'est pas le
même tout comme il n'a pas été le même
quand j'ai vu les images la vidéo suite
à l'interpellation par monsieur benalla
écrase de l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre qui étaient là le troisième
temps de vidéos et je pense qu'au vu ces
images
personne ne s'est dit il ya un problème
de violence policière il fallait
neutraliser quelqu'un qui avait un
comportement particulièrement agressif
vis-à-vis là d'une police autorisé pour
intervenir et donc je vous le redis
c'est dans le cadre d'un regard à un
moment donné sur un téléphone portable
de quelqu'un qui veut dire intervenait
dans le cadre de mes fonctions de
gendarmes et donc j'ai considéré que ma
responsabilité était d'informer sa
hiérarchie pour vérifier que ces faits
étaient connus et qu'ensuite il une
sanction
je précise d'ailleurs que le général
bio-farina qui a exclu de la réserve
président de la réserve de la réserve
n'ya presque la réserve de la présidence
de la république et qui a remis à
disposition
monsieur kraz aux gardes républicains a
pris une décision dès le 4 mai sur ce
sujet en aucun cas il ne m'en a informé
j'ai découvert cette décision et c'est
normal d'ailleurs j'ai découvert cette
décision en fait au moment de l'audition
donc voilà ce que je veux préciser c'est
que le regard que vous portez monsieur
sénateurs sueur à juste titre sur ces
faits là ne sont pas les mêmes quand on
vous dit que la personne intervenez dans
le cadre de fonction de gendarme
votre réponse et subtile au fond vous ne
nous dites pas les forces de l'ordre
étaient débordés et monsieur kraz agit
en bénévoles auxiliaires du service
public de la police pour leur prêter
main-forte nous dit à ce moment-là j'ai
j'ai la conviction parce que ce sont les
éléments qui me sont fournis qu'il
agissait comme gendarme réserviste de
l'elysée sous l'autorité de monsieur
benalla également de l'elysée et vous
n'êtes pas allé plus loin
c'est seulement ultérieurement que vous
avez compris que à la fois les forces de
police n'étaient toujours d'ailleurs il
d'ailleurs n'étaient pas débordés même
si elle était soumise à de très rude aso
et que le comportement des deux hommes
était totalement déplacé dans cette
affaire néanmoins vous estimez quand
même utile d'infliger une sanction à
monsieur kraz dans le même temps alors
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une incohérence
dans la réponse que vous nous faites
non parce que dans mon esprit à ce
moment-là j'applique la sanction décidée
par son autorité c'est à dire avec le
parallélisme des formes des quinze jours
et donc c'est sur la base de la lettre
de sanction de monsieur benalla que nous
avons repris de la même façon quasiment
la même lettre pour sanctionner
monsieur kraz en précisant bien dans la
lettre je tiens à votre disposition
et ça n'a pas été contestée par monsieur
kraz aucun moment qu'il n'intervenait
nullement dans le cas de ses activités
professionnelles sans en avoir informé
ni sa hiérarchie ni personne je tiens
cette lettre à votre disposition aymeric
merci beaucoup d
effectivement cela intéresse d'autres
commissions madame jourda merci monsieur
le président je insiste également sur ce
point et ma question sera peut-être
assez subjectif mais dans la mesure où
vous avez trouvé ce comportement
choquant tout le monde a trouvé ce
comportement choquant et tous ceux qui
se sont exprimés sur ce point et qui
toujours pas nécessairement vos ennemis
mais plutôt vos amis n'ont pas eu
d'épithètes assez forts pour qualifier
le comportement des uns et des autres
c'est à dire de monsieur védrine
monsieur kraz le premier mais il n'y
avait il pas à craindre une crise
politique qui d'ailleurs est avéré
aujourd'hui du fait que vous ayez
conserver en vous rend une personne qui
était capable de se livrer à un tel
comportement qu'ils soient ou pas
gendarme réserviste car je suis dessus
président sur ce point l'explication est
subtil de la comprenons mais elle est
subtil et elle ne passe pas facilement
dans le pignon est en réalité
aujourd'hui ce qui se dit ce qui
s'entend et que monsieur benalla et
monsieur kraz n'ont été démis leur
fonction des types définitivement
c'était vous vous êtes séparés d'eux et
de lui s'agissant de monsieur crasse que
parce que l'information est devenue
publique
cette sanction est elle véritablement
adapté c'est le délégué général alors je
ferai une correction sur la cause de la
sanction de la poster de licenciement
qui est liée à la mise en examen et
l'atteinte portée à l'image parce que en
droit du travail
le comportement en fait de monsieur kraz
en dehors de ses heures de travail
n'aurait pas été une cause réelle et
sérieuse de licenciement
et c'est vrai que sur la base de ces
éléments là au delà de mon sentiment
personnel qui n'a que peu d'importance
endroit j'étais dans cette contrainte là
mais vous avez raison madame la
sénatrice
avec les éléments que nous avons
aujourd'hui évidemment mon attitude
aurait été différente mais je vous le
dis la vérité si elle est unique elle
n'est pas forcément perçu de la même
façon en fonction des éléments que nous
avons est que j'avais à ce moment là
merci monsieur le délégué général
je crois que c'est madame di folco qui
avait demandé la parole merci monsieur
le président effectivement j'avais
demandé la parole au début de
l'intervention de cette audition pardon
malheureusement ou heureusement la
longue interrogations de monsieur le
président sur a déjà permis de répondre
à la question que je voulais poser
elle concernait en réalité le quantum de
la peine que je trouvais tout à fait
légère
quinze jours mais j'ai déjà dit
d'ailleurs au sujet de monsieur benalla
quinze jours d'exclusion à mon sens pour
une usurpation quand même deux fonctions
puisque ces personnes ne portaient des
insignes de policiers alors qu'ils ne le
sont pas et pour des violences physiques
15 jours de suspension me semblait tout
à fait inappropriée mais bon les
échanges que vous avez eus ont permis de
répondre à mon interrogation sur un
merci merci chers collègues
monsieur bonnecarrère merci monsieur le
président monsieur le délégué général
nous connaissons au t2 l'article 4 de la
constitution nous connaissons tous les
règles suivant lesquelles les partis
concourent à l'expression des suffrages
et les parties exercent leur activité
librement
vous avez donc en qualité délégué
général d'une liberté totale
d'organisation de votre formation
politique une liberté dans les
recrutements
est ce qu'il existe pour vous des
enseignements à tirer pour le mouvement
la république en marche ou pour les
formations politiques d'ailleurs en
général
des actions très critiquable de monsieur
benalla ou de monsieur crasse de leur
trajectoire
quels enseignements finalement tirez
vous de cette situation merci j'ai déjà
oui question complexe parce que au fond
il faudrait tirer l'enseignement du
comportement humain
j'ai toujours été rousseauiste pensant
que l'homme était naturellement bon mais
je sais que quelquefois il peut déraper
et je sais même pour avoir été un jeune
chef de cabinet dans un gouvernement
ancien à l'époque de la jospin était
premier ministre
comment au fond certaines positions
peuvent vous montez la tête et c'est la
question du facteur humain
la question du facteur humain dans toute
entreprise ou sens large
qu'elles soient politiques qu'elles
soient associative est une donnée qu'il
faut arriver à prendre en compte
je pense qu'en politique il faut une
exigence supplémentaire et que ça vaut
pour chacune et chacun d'entre nous et
que cette exigence doit permettre de
mettre en place des clics et des
systèmes de contrôle et de surveillance
pour ce qui concerne de façon très
pratique
j'avais demandé un audit de la question
de la gestion de sécurité du mouvement
la république en marche quand j'ai pris
mes fonctions j'ai d'ailleurs sollicité
enfin eu une contribution d'un cabinet
d'avocats le 26 avril donc avant ces
échéances là pour faire en sorte que
nous puissions avoir un service de
sécurité le plus transparent possible
parce que je sais que c'est
effectivement un sujet qui peut être
sensible et donc je vais demander à
avoir une expertise externe par un
cabinet d'avocats de la situation de la
sécurité de la réplique en marche que
j'entends mettre en oeuvre dans les
semaines qui viennent parce
qu'évidemment les anomalies constatées
par le fait que quelqu'un puisse
librement me dire à moi son employeur
même si je ne suis pas son employeur
direct et que je ne suis pas en
responsabilité la totalité des adhérents
réplique en marche mais puis je me dis
oh non j'agissais dans le cadre la
réserve de la gendarmerie que je puisse
le découvrir
d'ailleurs à ce moment là ce qui aurait
été honorable et qu'il aurait pu me dire
précédemment montrent qu'il y avait
quelques dysfonctionnements et donc je
suis en train de revoir l'organisation
notamment des sujets de sécurité du
mouvement la réplique en marche pour une
plus grande transparence et je rendrai
compte publiquement derrière des
décisions que je prendrais merci
monsieur le délégué général madame de la
gontrie
merci merci président de points vous
avez indiqué tout à l'heure que monsieur
kraz avait effectué 40 missions six mois
pour ponctuelles pour l'élysée novembre
2010 7 avril 2010 800 que
personnellement je n'ai pas très bien
compris si vous l'aviez découvert 140
mission j'imagine que ça se ressent dans
un agenda
par ailleurs vous avez indiquée
rapidement qu'il avait demandées auprès
du cnaps l'agrément dirigeants de
sociétés de sécurité qui lui avait été
refusé
en aviez-vous connaissance et sans
savez-vous les motifs deuxième chose
vous évoquez un entretien donc le 3 mai
montrez votre directeur de cabinet
françois blouvac ici présents et le
directeur de cabinet du président la
république monsieur strzoda concernant
la sanction en indiquant je reprends vos
mots que vous décidé d'appliquer un
parallélisme des formes
je mets de côté le l'aspect opportun de
ce parallélisme
mais pouvez vous donc nous confirmer que
vous êtes donc concerter pour décider de
la nature de la sanction qui devait être
appliqué à l'un et à l'autre et que donc
vous avez considéré l'un comme l'autre
mais en l'occurrence vous même que cette
sanction était adaptée monsieur le
délégué général
comme je venais de le préciser moi je
n'avais pas connaissance des activités
de gendarmes réservistes et de chef
d'escadron de monsieur kraz et et pour
tout vous dire c'est dans l'audition je
crois monsieur bio-farina que j'ai
appris qu'il était intervenu près de 40
fois dans les six mois indiqué en fait
les horaires sont des horaires adaptés
travaillant
gros les agents à sécurité une semaine
louis une semaine non et donc c'est dans
ce cadre là qu'il intervenait sans aura
besoin de nous en référé ni même de nous
en informer ni de nous en rendre compte
parce que c'est vraiment lié à cela j'ai
posé la question aux services juridiques
pour être complet avec vous dans le
contrat que nous avons il ya une clause
d'exclusivité et donc j'ai interrogé mes
services juridiques pour savoir si la
clause d'exclusivité exclus et
l'engagement dans la réserve de la
gendarmerie
politiquement je ne le souhaite pas mais
comme employeur qui dans une cadre d'une
procédure de licenciement je souhaitais
que ce soit indiqué vous comprenez
pourquoi politiquement je ne souhaite
pas parce que nous ne pouvons
qu'encourager l'engagement dans la
réserve et je pense que ce dont nous
parlons fait du mal à la réserve et
c'est dommage mais je parle là de façon
générale sur la question du refus j'en
ai fait état parce qu'il était dans un
article que j'ai lu ce matin de
libération le refus n'est pas sur son
agent agréé cnaps mais sur les
ressources un statut de chef
d'entreprise de sécurité il ne nous en
avait pas parlé et donc j'ignore les
raisons pour lesquelles étaient refusés
j'ignore les raisons pour lequel il
avait sollicité cela sur la question du
parallélisme des formes
il n'y a pas eu de concertation entre le
directeur de cabinet de la présidence de
répliquer mon directeur de caniel il ya
une information le directeur de cabinet
du président de la république nous a
fait parvenir la lettre qu'il a envoyée
à monsieur bénard et c'est sur la base
de cette lettre que nous aurons pris la
même lettre pour sanctionner monsieur
crasse merci monsieur le délégué général
madame mercier le président monsieur le
délégué général nous ressentons une
certaine confusion dans les rôles et les
missions de monsieur benalla auprès de
la présence de la république et de
monsieur kraz qui est votre salarié
nous avons bien compris que vous n'aviez
pas eu connaissance de tout son cursus
vous avez appris qu'il avait effectué 40
missions c'est quand même un nombre
important c'est ce était avec monsieur
benalla ou pas ce qui nous intéresse en
fait c'est de savoir si vous aviez noté
en tant qu'employeur près de votre
salarié un certain changement de
comportement est ce que les liens qui
s'étaient établis entre monsieur benalla
et le monsieur crasse pouvait d'éteindre
d'une certaine façon chez un monsieur
qui était gendarme réserviste août nous
louons les gendarmes et des réservistes
pour leurs valeurs pour la solidité
aussi de leur psychologie
donc pensez vous qu'il a pu se passer
quelque chose entre ces deux ans il n'y
a pour moi aucune confusion dans le rôle
de monsieur crasse de monsieur benalla
dans leurs activités professionnelles
qui sont évidemment bien distinctes je
n'ai pas observé de changement de
comportement mais je dois vous dire que
vincent kraz je le croisais quand il
était en poste le matin et que nous
échange et c'est un jugement de valeur
sur la qualité de l'homme qui m'a
toujours apparu sympathique mais nos
échanges se limitaient à bonjour et
j'imagine qu'il disait bonjour patron et
nos échanges se sont limités à ça donc
je peux pas faire une année de
psychologie que ce sera si un changement
de comportement ce que j'ai noté
notamment dans le cadre des auditions
qui ont été réalisés et notamment dans
les propos du général bio-farina c'est
que il nous l'indiquait tous les deux se
connaissaient depuis longtemps et qu'il
y avait un lien fort de l'un vis-à-vis
de l'autre et je dois vous préciser que
quand j'ai reçu monsieur kraz le 2 mai
au soir
je fais attention afin de tromper date
il m'a précisé qu effectivement c'était
le sens mais nahla qui avait dit de
venir et qu'en gros quand vincent
benalla lui disait pas vincent bénard à
monsieur benalla lui disait tu viens
alexandre de son prénom alexandre reynal
à lui et tu viens il venait je pense que
leur lien était aussi un lien d'autorité
peut-être naturel d'alexandre benalla
sur lui mais je n'ai pas plus de
précisions que cela
merci sassou permettait juste pour
savoir monsieur benalla à 26 ans qu'elle
est là je te mets se croiser c'est une
bonne question
gérer un peu plus de quarante je crois
qu'il a 45 ans mais l'autorité n'est pas
seulement liée à l'écart d'âge
[Musique]
alors même trend et voulait rebondir sur
eux non pardon vous voulez vous inscrire
et bien vous êtes inscrits monsieur le
président cela ne vous surprendra pas à
raison il est né en 1973 et donc il a 45
ans je vous remercie madame kadhai et
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le délégué général jeu juste une petite
question concernant le mans vous avez a
pris fin et eu connaissance des vidéos
via les réseaux sociaux donc le 2 mai et
à nous avons auditionné le chef de
cabinet du ministère de l'intérieur qui
nous disent que dès le 1er mai au soir
ils ont vu des vidéos ils ont eu
connaissance de la présence de monsieur
benalla et de monsieur grâce repéré
effectivement comme étant un des
salariés de la république en marche
avez vous bu vous des contacts avec le
ministère de l'intérieur avant votre que
les gens via les réseaux sociaux ou
après la connaissance de ces faits qui
étaient évidemment commis dans le cadre
d'opérations menées sous la
responsabilité de monsieur le délégué
général
non la formation et est remonté plus tôt
par les réseaux que vous avez pu
constater vis-à-vis du mystère à
l'intérieur mais qui ne m'en a pas
informés ni la préfecture brise qui dans
l'absolu est normal je pense que vincent
grass n'avaient pas été identifiées par
ces dispositifs là c'est ce qu'a précisé
le préfet de police notamment dans son
édition
moi ma seule information est lié on va
dire à la rumeur dans la maison la
réplique en marche et elle est arrivée
le 1er mai est enfermé le site de la
réplique en marche est enfermée elle
n'est arrivée que dans la journée du 2
mai j'aurais pris connaissance que le
soir même j'ai eu aucun contact à ce
moment là avec le ministère de
l'intérieur et le seul échange que j'ai
pu avoir son postérieur au 18 juillet
dans des échanges que je peux avoir avec
le ministre de l'intérieur mais
postérieurement à cela et aucun moment
il ne m'a informé de la situation
madame n'appliquer déjà posé une
question et
rebondir sur votre réponse tout
simplement monsieur le délégué général
j'aurais voulu savoir si monsieur kraz
été avait un port d'armes
parce qu'on parle de sécurité on a parlé
monsieur benalla de son port d'armes et
monsieur kraz avait-il une arme sur lui
quand il était enfant
monsieur castaner alors d'abord s'il
avait une arme sur lui
moi je ne sais pas mais le rapport de
l'igpn précise que les images vidéos
sont beaucoup plus parlant de s'agissant
de monsieur kraz pour qui le port
d'armes de catégorie b constitué l'un
des chefs d'inculpation et dans ce cadre
je ne doute pas que la justice puisse
permettre d'établir les faits mais je
pense qu'il ya un faisceau d'indicés
suffisant pour que des têtes mises en
examen dans ce cadre là mais je rappelle
évidemment la question de la présomption
d'innocence
ensuite il faut avoir en tête que
vincent kraz n'avait pas de port d'armes
à ce moment les informations en ma
possession que si pendant la campagne
électorale 2 autorisation de détention
d'armes avaient été accordées au moment
de la campagne avec toi elles sont
tombées à la fin de la campagne
électorale et qu'en aucun cas ni
monsieur benalla dans ce cadre là ni
monsieur krasniqi conques ne peut
aujourd'hui prétendre avoir une
détention d'armes et du coup usé de ses
fonctions à la république en marche pour
prétendre cela
merci de cette réponse monsieur richard
commission collectivement de réfléchir
pour savoir si on pouvait faire des
observations à l'encontre du délégué
général de dents marche sur
l'application de l'article 40
ce que les termes mêmes de l'article 40
prévoient que toute autorité constituée
tout officier public ou fonctionnaire
qui dans l'exercice de ses fonctions
acquiert la connaissance d'un crime ou
d'un délit est tenu d'en donner avis
donc monsieur castaner en tant que
membre du gouvernement et bien une
autorité constituée ou un fonctionnaire
public totalement raison dans le cadre
de ses fonctions qu'il a connaissance de
fait répréhensible imputable à monsieur
kraz mais dans le cadre de ses fonctions
de dirigeant associatif et donc il me
semble que les termes mêmes de l'article
40 ne pouvait pas le conduire à se poser
la question de l'appliquer dans son
corps ou le monde il pouvait néanmoins
le conduire à se poser la question de
savoir s'il fallait pas dénoncé au
parquet des faits délictueux autrement
que dans le cadre de l'article 40
présents j'ai eu l'occasion
effectivement de regarder ce sujet parce
que je voulais préparer notre audition
je n'ai pas souhaité soulevé cette
exception de droit qui me paraît juste
parce qu'effectivement je crois que la
question était aussi sur la
responsabilité politique un responsable
politique et c'est pour ça que j'ai
voulu n'ont pas évacué la question mais
plutôt ne pas esquiver et assumer la
réponse de fond que je souhaitais vous
apporter mes endroits
le débat peut effectivement avoir lieu
alem jordan merci monsieur le président
monsieur avez vous connaissance d'autres
personnels dans marche qui effectuent
des tâches ou des missions de sécurité
pour l'elysée notamment en tant que
réserviste notamment vous avez complété
la question à monsieur figé non c'est
parce que vous voulez imposer une tout à
l'heure monsieur le délégué général
j'ai vu que cela avait été évoqué dans
une des auditions j'ai demandé en
interne aux services si une personne
était connu comme relevant du cadre
l'homme apprécié que non je pense qu'il
s'agissait d'une personne dont je n'ai
pas le nom qui a été un moment en
responsabilité et je ne sais pas où et
quand dans quel cadre et qui avait cela
mais je pense que ça n'est plus le cas
depuis de longs mois
merci de votre réponse possible de
compte
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
délégué général
dans le rapport de l'igpn il est indiqué
que monsieur kraz et n'a pas été comptés
la présence de monsieur crise n'a pas
été contestée lors le 1er mai compte
tenu du fait qu'il avait été présenté
comme un accompagnant d'une personne qui
s'affichait qui était reconnu comme
compte comme membres de la présidence de
la république
cela pose un problème sur la prééminence
de la présidence de la république
puisque à partir du moment où la
personne a été présenté avec ce statut
rien n'a été vérifiés et on l'a laissé
faire qu'est ce que vous en tirer comme
conséquence politique sur la place de la
présidence de la république dans nos
institutions
qu'est ce que vous en tirer comme
conséquence sur ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour éviter que cela puisse se
reproduire avec simplement un affichage
qui contribuent en qui en fait n'est qu
un passe droit et est ce que vous ne
pensez pas que par rapport au débat que
nous avons pu avoir l'année dernière au
moment de la discussion budgétaire sur
des cabinets ministériels qui étaient
réduits parfois un minimum qui les
empêchait de fonctionner correctement
par rapport à une présidence de la
république qui prend de plus en plus de
place est ce que ces événements vous
conduisent à faire évoluer vos positions
sur la place de la présidence de la
république dans nos institutions et sur
la manière d'encadrer sa prééminence
oui c'est une question importante
la maladie du pouvoir dans tous les
temps et sur tous les continents ç'a
toujours été la vue de pouvoir c'est
pour ça qu'on a inventé les
constitutions monsieur le délégué
général
sur la question de la vérification de
l'habilitation je n'ai pas à me
prononcer sur ce sujet mais j'ai
effectivement lieu comme vous l'anomalie
constatée dans le rapport de l'igpn sur
les conséquences à en tirer d'abord les
conséquences on va dire organisationnel
l'igpn fait des préconisations j'ai pu
noter que le ministre de l'intérieur
avait retenu la totalité des
préconisations avait demandé qu'elles
soient mises en oeuvre notamment sur la
question du statut d'observateur
ensuite je crois que vos propos m'amène
à une question politique sur les
conséquences politiques vos propos
d'ailleurs sont une interprétation
politique d'une situation
elle vous appartient je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit dans ce cadre là que je
puisse vous y répondre mais peut-être
plutôt sedan un débat que nous pourrions
avoir dans d'autres instances ce que je
sais c'est que au fond vincent kraz
était un chargé de mission à la peu
alexandre bédat était un chargé de
mission identifiés comme tels à la
présidence de la république et qu'il a
eu un comportement individuel
inacceptable qui ne remet en aucun cas
en cause la présence de la république et
la façon dont le président de la
république exerce son autorité
[Musique]
merci de cette réponse monsieur françois
noël buffet merci monsieur le président
monsieur le délégué général
nous avons appris que pendant sa peine
de suspension
monsieur benalla avaient été rémunérés
est ce que monsieur kraz par
parallélisme des formes
l'at il été pendant cette même période
dès ma deuxième question monsieur voyez
pas que la question soit malicieuse
c'est une question de fait n'est ce pas
important
oui absolument me semble-t-il et puis
monsieur
benalla a fait l'objet d'une
rétrogradation qu'en est-il également
toujours par par alison parallélisme des
formes de monsieur vincent kraz merci
monsieur le délégué général
il a fait l'objet d'une suspension de
ses fonctions entre le 4 et le 18 mai
elle était signifié par lettre
recommandée avec accusé réception et il
n'y avait pas de suspension de salaire
alors sur la rétrogradation
là je vais être un peu
oui
et donc je vais je vais préciser que
pour ce qui est de la rétrogradation les
fonctions de monsieur craps n'était pas
tout à fait les mêmes que celles de
monsieur benalla donc il m'était
difficile d'organiser par prendre je le
dis tout à l'heure il n'a plus fait
aucun déplacement extérieur
dans ce cadre là et de toute façon il
n'a jamais eu l'occasion de
m'accompagner dans mes déplacements
contrairement à ce qui est écrit dans la
presse ce matin ma sécurité personnelle
est assurée par mes officiers de
sécurité
mais je voudrais préciser quand même sur
ce sujet quelle souvent un sujet de
fantasmes que je crois que toute femme
et tout homme politique qui ont fait
l'objet d'un accompagnement pour leur
sécurité savent que ce n'est un plaisir
pour personne et que personne ne
revendique d'avoir le plaisir d'être
accompagné par des femmes et deux hommes
armés j'aimerais vous préciser que j'ai
fait l'objet d'une tentative d'attentât
qu'un réseau terroriste a été démantelée
que cinq personnes sont actuellement
toujours en prison et que quand vous
apprenez que ces gens vous ont suivi
dans votre commune à forcalquier pour ce
qui me concerne avec la volonté de vous
égorgez vous dit que finalement on
serait mieux sans officier de sécurité
dans un système où nous n'aurions pas
besoin mais je précise au delà de cette
remarque là qui est que ma sécurité
n'ait assumé que par les officiers de
sécurité qui sont mis à disposition du
ministre que je suis monsieur crasse n'a
jamais été en charge de ma sécurité et
donc il n'avait pas besoin de connaître
d'évolution sur ce sujet merci de cette
réponse monsieur kerrouche merci
monsieur présidente je voulais
intervenir à la fin mais puisque vous me
donnez la parole maintenant je voulais
te demander à monsieur le délégué
général monsieur questionnaire vous avez
vous avez déclaré la semaine dernière
que les oppositions étaient la coalition
de ceux qui n'aiment pas l'état des
séditieux de ceux qui rêvent d'une
république affaiblie avides de têtes qui
roulent
je voulais savoir si vous aviez été
rassurés cette matinée par votre
audition au sénat quant à nos quant à
nos attentions
vu la qualité de nos débats et vous
rassurer dans le sens que nous allons
tous nous avons tous la même volonté
d'aller dans une transparence pour la
pour la république
se le dise général j'espère que vous
avez préparé comme moi cette audition et
que vous avez pu en allant sur mon
compte facebook fait lire la totalité du
texte dans lequel je parle qu'il ya eu
un rassemblement d'opposants virgule
j'imagine que vous classer dans cette
catégorie au moins l'assemblée nationale
le groupe politique auquel vous
appartenez est membre d'un groupe
d'opposition virgule de séditieux
virgule et j'ai donné un certain nombre
d'éléments
je ne considère pas que tous les
opposants sont des séditieux bien au
contraire mais je tiens à vous rassurer
si vous avez pensé cela et urbanité que
nous vous connaissons me faisais
spontanément exclure cette hypothèse
mais il faut reconnaître que la phrase
était ambiguë mais l'interprétation de
la virgule est importante je vous en
remercie alors madame traîne les oui
merci monsieur le président ce délégué
général ma question portait en fait sur
l'effectivité de la sanction mais
néanmoins j'ai une petite question
complémentaire précédemment vous étiez
membre actif du parti socialiste et vous
ne pouviez bien évidemment pas ignorer
le la la sangle pas la sanction mais
disons lorsque monsieur montebourg était
ministre et que monsieur benalla
travailler pour lui que suit un
comportement non recommandable à
monsieur montebourg lui a demandé de ne
plus travailler pour lui dans un souci
de transparence mais également de
sécurité
à aucun moment vous n'avez vous parlez
converser signalé cette situation
lorsque monsieur benalla a été recruté
dans le cadre de la campagne de monsieur
macro est ensuite allé disciples je suis
que cette année
sous réserve de me tromper je crois que
personne ici et compris ceux qui sont
restés au parti socialiste pour
reprendre votre remarque liminaire
n'avait entendu dire que monsieur
montebourg aurait demandé ou virer son
chauffeur voilà donc c'est une
information qui est tombé d'aupic
monsieur montebourg indiqué mon statut
de membre du parti socialiste sans
aucune responsabilité nationale du parti
suisse m'a mené par à connaître de ce
genre de décision des ministres du
gouvernement donc m'avait interrogé sur
le fait de savoir si je ne pouvait pas
ignorer
je vous dis je l'ignoré totalement si ça
avait été le cas si j'en avais eu
connaissance je pense que j'en aurais
préféré
merci monsieur le délégué général
monsieur fichiers oui monsieur le
président monsieur le délégué général
je crois que ce qui nous interroge tous
c'est cette notion un petit peu d'amitié
complice qu'il y as entre monsieur
benalla messieurs kraz et qui aboutit au
fait qu'ils se donnent rendez-vous
quelque part le jour du 1er mai pour
être là ne servent à tort l'autre rien
du tout observer les comportements vont
un petit peu comment sait on les
manifestations puis de devenir un
terreau plan sans que jamais personne ne
les interrogent et on arrive à une
situation de brutalité qu'on constate
qu'on a vu tout sur les vidéos et là
encore personne ne les interroger depuis
le début d'une audition en fait la
constante c'est que chacun nous dit mais
en fait on ne savait pas ce qui veut
dire que l'on peut circuler comme ça
entre les services entre les mailles du
filet pour arriver à des actions qui
sont extrêmement graves et la question
que je voulais vous poser c'est de
savoir si au sein du mouvement elle rêve
vous aviez été amené à intervenir au
service ou votre environnement pour
savoir s'il n'y avait pas d'autres
personnes qui pouvaient être associé à
un moment ou un autre à ce type de
comportement qui qui s'inscrit en fait
dans une forme de dap unités liées à la
fête qu'on y est
on est défendu par touches en face la
cause n'est pas attaquable puisqu'on est
un des services du gouvernement et de
l'elysée
monsieur le délégué général question
subjective que vous poser avec elle je
vais répondre par l'objectivité d'abord
de la révision du statut d'observateur
on voit bien une anomalie dans la façon
dont monsieur benalla c'est considérer
invités et dont beaucoup ont considéré
qu'il l'était et puis le fait qu'il
vienne avec une personne qui n'est pas
du tout est vanité qu'il présente juste
comme un collaborateur et que ça suffise
pour que personne n'ose dire vous avez
raison c'est une anomalie et donc il est
important d'y mettre un terme je crois
que le rapport de l'igpn fait des
préconisations et que leur mise en
oeuvre de permettre de sécuriser cela
sur le deuxième élément vous évoquez
même des comportements qui au fond ne
faut intervenir personnes
j'ai en tête les propos du préfet
delpech qui dit notamment pour ceux qui
ne connaissaient pas monsieur crasé
qu'il voit intervenir dans les forces de
l'ordre que beaucoup ont pensé qu'il
était un policier et qu'il était du coup
légitime à intervenir même si on peut
conseil qu'il y avait une disproportion
dans les conditions de son intervention
donc ça veut dire effectivement tout
cela doit être revu pour ce qui concerne
l'interrogation que vous me posez pour
savoir si je me suis questionnée suppose
art s'il y avait ce risque là de dérives
au sein de la république en marche
je ne les fais mais qu'a posteriori
parce que je ne pensais pas que ce
risque puisse exister mais évidemment
dès le lundi suivant le 18 juillet j'ai
réuni l'ensemble des personnels pour
leur dire deux choses la première c'est
que notre maison devait être une maison
transparente totalement transparente
notamment dans le cadre de l' enquête
judiciaire qui pouvait amener à ce qui
est des opérations de justice qui soit
procédé dans cette maison et donc j'ai
indiqué à chacun qu'il fallait se
préparer à assurer toute la transparence
sur ces sujets et la seconde j'ai
interrogé pour savoir si effectivement
il y avait d'autres personnes dans la
maison qui pouvoir ce statut double de
gendarmes réservistes par exemple il a
été précisé que nous c'est la richard
veut rebondir sur la réponse du
président la solution une suggestion
pour le travail de la commune
merci aux ternois et des halles organise
et gère collègues mais j'en suis membre
et vous plaît comme chacun d'entre nous
je suis là pour la manif mais voyons la
liberté de la vérité et pour rien
d'autre et c'est la première fois qu'il
est fait mention de de l'écho de presse
suivant lequel monsieur arnaud
montebourg aurait eu monsieur benalla
comme chauffeur arnaud bonhoure était
ministre du développement du
redressement productif à bercy j'ai
beaucoup de mal à imaginer que quelqu'un
était était chauffeur d'un ministres de
bercy sans être fonctionnaire eh bien je
crois que cette remarque est judicieuse
et je me propose de demander à monsieur
montebourg bat ou 6,7
si cette information est réel essayez de
la de l'important c'est ce qu'il a fait
si elle si elle a effectivement si ces
faits sont établis ce qu'il a fait
ensuite à partir de là je remercie cher
collègue monsieur le délégué général
je voudrais apporter une précision parce
que j'étais imprécis il y a deux
personnes salariées de la république en
match qui sont engagés dans la réserve
de gendarmerie mais qui n'ont aucun lien
avec la réserve la gendarmerie de la
présidence de la république
donc je tiens les noms je peux peut-être
pas le dire publiquement mais je tiens
les noms à votre disposition mais du
coup je ne savais pas non plus mais
comme je questionnais deux jeunes femmes
qui sont engagés mais qui sont des
fonctions administratives et qui sont à
côté de cela j'en ai un réserviste mais
pas du tout dans le cadre de la présence
de la république ni même de la garde
républicaine je crois mais je vous
apporterai ces précisions là alors
monsieur campons mai
délégué général vous avez dans votre
déclaration préliminaire fait pas de
l'émotion et de l'importance que vous
êtes à chier à ce qui vient de se passer
or parallèlement on a le sentiment que
parmi les autres responsables dans
marche les députés qui s'exprime
régulièrement ces jours ci on a
l'impression que la consigne est de
minimiser cette opération des éléments
de langage répétés autant que faire se
peut parle de 150 tonnes de mousse pour
15 g de savon ça a sûrement été pensés
quelque part puisqu'on entend cette
déclaration de manière récurrente la
manière dont travaille dans kate a été
conduit chez nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale par vos amis
montre aussi la volonté d'étouffer de
limites et vous même dans une formule
assez lapidaire avait qualifié monsieur
beynat de bagagistes
c'était effectivement au moment de la
coupe du monde enfin il faut quand même
rappeler
puisqu'on vous en face de nous ce mot
est ce qu'elle a est-ce qu'à la faveur
des investigations du parlement et
singulièrement de cette commission d
enquête sous l'autorité du président bas
et de ses rapporteurs qui ne cesse de
montrer les incohérences les
dérèglements de toute cette affaire est
ce que votre sentiment en tant que
déléguée générale de la république en
marche se modifie et puisque nous sommes
à la veille d'une réforme
constitutionnelle importante est ce que
vous considérez contrairement au
sentiment qu'on a pu avoir encore une
fois à travers toutes ces déclarations
que le rôle du parlement et
singulièrement celui du sénat est
important pour équilibrer faire en sorte
que lorsque des affaires d'état éclate
de la sorte et bien toute la lumière
puisse être faite par respect pour
l'opinion publique
alors la question s'adresse aussi un peu
au secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations au parlement
la position normale surtout alors
monsieur le ministre est délégué général
monsieur le président vous êtes
sentiment que certains ont voulu
minimiser
peut-être que je prends le sentiment que
certains veulent exagéré quand on
qualifie ce dont nous parlons d' affaire
d'état
mais tout cela est subjectif vous venez
de parler d' affaire d'état je considère
dans mon référentiel à moi que nous ne
sommes pas dans une affaire d'état et je
n'ai pas l'impression de minimiser
vous voyez comme quoi le positionnement
politique selon où l'on se place
peut on avoir un regard différent tout
comme sur le fait que vous m'avez prêté
des propos d'avoir qualifié monsieur
benalla de bagagistes je voudrais
rappeler mes propos précisément et je
voudrais vous préciser que j'ai fait
cela le 19 juillet je n'ai pas cherché à
fuir une quelconque responsabilité ni à
minimiser
dès le 19 juillet je suis la première
personnalité de la réplique en marche à
me rendre sur un plateau télé pour
parler de cette affaire
et quand la journaliste m'interpelle
elle utilise un mot pour parler des
événements qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
de la gravité je la corriger
immédiatement voulu dire que je
considère que ces actes sont d'une très
grande gravité
et donc je n'ai jamais cherché à
minimiser je les fais dès le 19 juillet
un moment où assez peu de paroles
avaient été données et je vous le dis je
suis le premier responsable politique à
l'est sur un plateau télé pour justement
parler et évoquer la gravité qui ma
première intervention et de corriger la
journaliste non pas pour lui donner une
leçon de sémantique mais pour qualifier
par proportionnellement à l'émotion qui
était la mienne sur la gravité de ces
faits et donc sur la question du
bagagiste quand la question m'est posée
dans une autre émission c'est sur bfm
rmc un matin je réponds je ne suis pas
l'employeur de cette personne je ne sais
pas quelles étaient ses missions j'ai
entendu dire qu'il était en charge de la
logistique et notamment des bagages
voyez votre propos mais qui a été
extrêmement relayée par certains qui
nous écoutent aujourd'hui est quand même
un tout petit peu caricatural par
rapport à ce que je dis surtout que
quand on sait que notamment le gspr dans
les voyages officiels est en charge
aussi de la logistique et des bagages
on peut considérer que le raccourci qui
a été fait par quelques années mon
propos est insultant y compris pour les
agents du gesbert
et ça amène d'ailleurs et ça a été
évoqué dans certaines auditions la
réflexion pour savoir si vos débats
mieux organiser cela que je considère ce
n'est pas le rôle d'un monde du gspr qu
de devoir de gérer les bagages des
délégations officielles
enfin sur votre question plus politique
s'il ya bien une personne qui ici
pensent et assume l'importance du
bicamérisme un peu dans le sens
d'ailleurs des propos du président de la
république tenus au congrès il ya
quelques jours sur ce sujet c'est bien
moins parce que je vis au quotidien
effectivement là je prends ma casquette
de secrétaire d'état aux relations avec
le mans
la particularité de la proche que vous
avez et la responsabilité que vous
incarnez et donc je n'ai sur ce sujet
aucun doute sur cela et d'ailleurs les
propositions de modification
constitutionnelle sur lequel l'assemblée
nationale a décidé d'empêcher le travail
une partie de l'assemblée nationale
courant du mois de juillet ne cherche en
aucun cas à minimiser le rôle de
l'assemblée nationale ou du sénat mais
cherche au contraire à trouver la
meilleure fluidité possible et tous les
propos tous les échanges ont eu lieu
entre le président larcher le premier
ministre le président de la république
ont toujours été dans le sens d'être le
garant le président mais aussi celui qui
écoute et qui entend mettre en oeuvre
pour le premier ministre pour le
président de la république de
l'importance du bicamérisme qui est un
fondement même de notre constitution et
comme l'a rappelé le président philippe
à la constitution est certainement le
meilleur rempart que nous avons pour les
libertés publiques
merci monsieur le délégué général et 6
mai autour de vous j'ai senti qu'on a
prouvé ce dernier propos sans réserve et
donc et je donne la parole à monsieur
lefebvre
monsieur le président monsieur le
délégué général vous avez évoqué un
audit interne ceux concernant la
sécurité
avez vous connaissance avec vous si
monsieur kraz avait où il a été
dirigeant d'une société privée de
sécurité ou si la départ de
dans une société de même type puisqu'on
a évoqué un refus d'agrément mais
j'aimerais savoir si vous avez
connaissance de quelques activités dans
le domaine sécurité sur un aspect plus
privé monsieur le délégué général alors
sur le dernier volet de sa demande
d'agrément ou comme responsable
d'entreprise je n'ai pas d'information
je les presser tout à l'heure je sais
qu'il a eu un statut d'auto-entrepreneur
parce que pendant la campagne électorale
il a été payé sur des prestations avec
un statut d'auto entrepreneur voilà le
seul statut que je lui connais dans ce
cadre là à ce moment là je vous remercie
madame des riez vais rien merci monsieur
le président monsieur le délégué général
alors la question que je voulais poser
vient d'être posée effectivement et je
voulais savoir quand vous aviez eu
connaissance de celle ce refus
d'habilitation et si ça ne devait pas
faire jouer la clause d'exclusivité dont
vous aviez parlé par rapport à son
contrat de travail puisse le fait de
demander une habilitation pour une
présidence de société peut effectivement
faire que ailier deux emplois
a priori est par ailleurs voilà je vous
avais aussi répondu à votre question qui
était de savoir pour quelle société
était prestataire monsieur kraz lors de
la campagne mais apparemment c'est j'ai
bien compris c'est en tant qu'auto
entrepreneurs confirmés
je confirme qu'au vu des informations
que j'ai c'est effectivement sur le
statut d'auto-entrepreneur sa base des
factures que j'ai pu voir et qui me sont
remontés et sur la connaissance du refus
d'agrément de son statut genou pour tout
vous dire qui à recevoir lors de la
parution de l'article sur sur numérique
qui est parue ce matin en format papier
à aucun moment il n'avait informé ni sa
hiérarchie ni des ressources humaines en
fonction des éléments que j'ai de sa
volonté créer une entreprise
je vous remercie madame eliane assassi
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
délégué général vous êtes auditionné ce
matin en votre qualité donc de déléguée
générale de la république en marche mais
chacune et chacun sait ici que vous êtes
par ailleurs membre du gouvernement
chargé des relations avec le parlement
et vous avez d'ailleurs pris cette
casquette ce matin pour répondre à un
certain nombre de questions à la faveur
de la sphère qui nous occupe de pensez
vous pas qu'il serait utile voire même
nécessaire au nom de la démocratie et de
la transparence de s'interroger
effectivement sur le fait d'être à la
fois premier responsable d'une formation
politique est membre d'un gouvernement
quel qu'il soit monsieur le délégué
général à pompe ce qui me concerne
non
nous avons posé la question si je
m'interroge je vous réponds non je pense
je pense madame la présidente que faire
de la politique pour un ministre d'un
gouvernement n'est pas un gros mot
assumé de faire de la politique
quels que soient les choix qu'on fait
nous avons des choix différents sont
parfaitement respectable n'est pas un
handicap
et je pense que vouloir dépolitiser la
fonction ministérielle
en considérant qu'on ne peut pas être
responsable d'un parti politique vous me
posez une question je tente de répondre
je pense que vouloir dépolitiser la
fonction ministère dont considérant que
des responsabilités bénévoles de
responsable d'un parti politique
certains rémunère et considère que ça
doit être un engagement rémunérer ce
n'est pas le cas de la république en
marche serait incompatible avec un
engagement ministériel et pourquoi pas
un engagement de parlementaires de
sénateur demers ne me semble pas ne me
semble pas la bonne approche de ce
dossier je pense dans mes fonctions de
secrétaire d'état en charge des
relations avec le parlement nous nous
croisons quelques fois n'avoir jamais
mis en avant est jamais orienté mes
choix en fonction d'une appétence
politique mais plutôt toujours en
fonction du meilleur fonctionnement
il n'est pas toujours parfait on me le
reproche quelques fois notamment lors de
la dernière conférence des présidents
mais un meilleur fonctionnement de nos
institutions et des relations entre le
gouvernement et le sénat notamment
merci enfin ultime question sauf si
monsieur surfe lui aussi opposé de notre
rapporteur madame jourdain
mais merci monsieur le président
peut-être une petite observation pour
commencer j'avoue rester un peu sur ma
faim s'agissant du caractère approprié
de la sanction pour les faits que vous
qualifiez d'inqualifiable tout cas
extrêmement grave
de monsieur crasse puisqu'il s'agit
simplement si j'ai bien compris ce que
vous nous avez indiqué de le dispenser
trail pendant quinze jours tout en
rémunérant bon ceci étant vous vous êtes
longuement expliqué sur ce point je ne
reposera pas de questions ma question
s'adresse sera plutôt à monsieur le
ministre puisque vous allez reprendre
dans quelques instants ses fonctions sur
ce qu'a déjà indiqué d'ailleurs le
président quand bon vous savez que nous
nous soucions ici de savoir qu elle a
été aussi la réalité de la sanction de
monsieur benalla et notamment quelle a
été la nature de la rétrogradation dont
il a fait l'objet
et à ce titre nous l'avons vu dans le
car qui a conduit les bleus suite à leur
victoire de coupe du monde sur des
champs elysées ce qui a étonné tout le
monde et vous êtes exprimés dans les
circonstances que vous avez indiquée
nous vous avez dit que vous aviez
entendu dire que il s'occupait de la
logistique
je vous rassure tout le monde dans cette
commission avait compris qu'il
s'agissait de la logistique
cela signifie t'il que vous vous êtes
vous même inquiété que vous avez été
vous même surpris de le voir encore dans
ce type de fonction et que vous êtes en
kit savoir ce qu'il faisait là en toute
hypothèse
vous avez entendu dire qui vous a donné
cette information
monsieur le délégué général alors on
poser la question comme ministre de
savoir quelle est l'évolution du poste
d'un chargé de mission à l'elysée dont
communiste ne maintiendrait pas de
répondre sur l'organisation interne de
l'elysée je ne le ferai pas surtout que
comme je les dis lors de l'interview
vous évoquez je n'ai aucune information
n'étant bon employeur et j'ai cherché
parce que la petite polémique qui m'a
été prêté sur le mot bagagistes m'a
légèrement agacé je cherchais l'origine
de ce entendu dire je n'ai pas trouvé
donc je ne peux pas vous répondre
c'est d'ailleurs l'intérêt de la formule
entendu dire mais c'est vrai que j'ai
cherché à quel moment ce truc il était
venu et je suis honnête avec vous je
n'ai pas retrouvé parce que sinon je le
pense que je l'aurais retweeter
immédiatement pour me protéger des
moqueries dont j'ai fait l'objet en
ayant non plus pas de votre part madame
la co rapporteurs évidemment et donc je
ne suis pas en mesure de répondre à
cette question là monsieur le président
sur ces madame jourda qui me donne
d'idée quand même de revenir sur cette
question monsieur le délégué général et
monsieur le ministre
quand même quand on voit la gravité des
faits inadmissible inacceptable
peut-être d'ailleurs une seconde à faire
le même jour du 1er mai peut-être il y a
donc les sanctions pour la république en
marche vous en avait parlé pour l'elysée
la sanction de mise à pied avec une
conséquence financière sur les congés et
ensuite une fois que c'est fini
la mise à pied on voit cette personne se
retrouvaient dans des circonstances
extrêmement visible extrêmement sensible
l'arrivée des cendres de simone veil les
antoine veil -le au panthéon
c'est quand même un acte très forte la
république
l'arrivée des bleus on en a parlé le 14
juillet la tribune officielle du 14
juillet est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas été
tout simple quand même d'exfiltrer
monsieur benalla de toutes ses
responsabilités
après les 15 jours est ce qu'il n'ya pas
quelque chose de choquant à ce qu'il
apparaisse de cette manière
y compris à roissy par rapport aux
gendarmes
alors je vous demande simplement votre
sentiment
vous savez que il y à une lecture très
simple de cette affaire qui est que
finalement on a cherché à faire que cet
épisode soit étouffée j'emploie le mot
ce qui aurait peut-être été le cas si
quelques journalistes ne s'était pas
acquis de cette affaire et si une
information n'avait pas été livrés
et je vous demande votre sentiment par
rapport à cela parce que finalement les
sanctions véritable se sont déclenchés
bien plus tard et c'est là le problème
principal finalement et je rappelle que
la justice s'est saisie elle n'a pas été
saisie elle s'est saisie
donc c'est quand même la question
principale et je ne vous demande pas de
réponse je vous demande quel est votre
sentiment par rapport à cela
alors j'ai tenté sous l'autorité de
votre commission des lois réunis sous
forme de commission denquête de répondre
non pas par des sentiments annoncé par
des faits et je souhaite aujourd'hui
devant vous restez sur les faits pas sur
les sentiments pas sur les commentaires
il ya d'autres lieux pour cela et j'ai
eu l'occasion de m'exprimer sur cela
mais devant votre commission jeu soit en
rester sur les faits ce qu'il paraît
l'essentiel merci monsieur le délégué
général ne vous en ferons part proche
mais alors il ya une troisième ultime
question elle vient et vient de fornel
buffet merci monsieur le président et
délégué général monsieur vincent kraz
était un réserviste actif de la
gendarmerie travail est donc avec
l'elysée vous nous avez indiqué tout à
l'heure que deux autres personnes au
sein de la république en marche était
également des réservistes
et puis devant l'assemblée nationale le
général bio farina a indiqué qu'une
autre personne est maintenant de la
république en marche était réserviste au
sein de l'elysée peut vous nous dire si
vous avez connaissance de cette personne
est ce une des deux que vous avez cités
tout à l'heure où une autre
éventuellement qui exerce cette mission
merci monsieur le délégué général
non je redis la réponse que j'apportais
tout dollars sur sept autres personnes
dont j'ai découvert la possible
existence lors de l'audition
nous n'avons aucune trace je vous
réponde plus franchement possible et
donc nous allons creuser et ensuite il
ya deux autres personnes deux jeunes
femmes qui sont dans la réserve qui ne
sont pas liées à la présidence mais dont
je communiquerai pour votre complète
information les noms au président et du
appartient évidemment s'il le souhaite
de vous les communiquer non pas pour les
cacher mais parce que je pense que ça
relève aussi de leur engagement privé
mais je voulais communiquer à la suite
de notre entretien ainsi que
l'organigramme ainsi que la lettre de
notification de la sanction
si j'ai bien noté les trois pièces mais
je pense monsieur présentes voulaient
complet très si besoin est nous ferons
diligence il me reste maintenant
monsieur le délégué général dé monsieur
le ministre à vous remercier de votre
coopération avec la commission des lois
il s'agit de la dernière audition de ce
cycle d'auditions et nous reprendrons
nos travaux à la rentrée
je vous remercie la séance est suspendue
le temps de permettre aux membres de la
commission de l'eau des lois de
rejoindre la salle de la commission des
lois pour notre séance ordinaire nous
avons à examiner le texte sur
l'immigration
je vous remercie la séance est levée